a full-blown revolt against ultra woke
l.a district attorney george gascong
an astounding 98 percent of los angeles
prosecutors support a recall against
their hyper-progressive boss and perhaps
for good reason gascon scrambling to
save face after giving a light sentence
a very light sentence to a child
molester caught on tape celebrating the
da's policies that spared her years
behind bars despite attacking a
ten-year-old girl
don't worry about it it's a strike but
they're going to plea i'm going to plead
out to him and plead guilty they're
going to be on probation and it's going
to be dropped it's going to be done done
i won't have to register once or nothing
for an offender you don't have to
register i won't have to do none of that
so what are they going to do to you that
nothing
gascon claims he did not know about
these tapes before sentencing the child
molester who now identifies as you may
have figured out as a woman
but the prosecutor on the case shea
sanna who handled it says gekko gascon
and his inner circle all knew about the
shocking jailhouse audio
i received an email
saying that management
wanted
the tapes they heard i had the tapes
because i sent them to everybody
involved in the tubbs case the
department of probation department of
mental health
everybody that needed to know
what was on the tapes i sent them a link
let me rather than focus on the d.a i
want to focus on the perp here
hannah tubbs who was james tubbs at the
time this was committed
he didn't identify as a woman until he
was facing right you know
he thought a life sentence but a long
time in jail i wonder if the way
some claim
transsexuals are gaming sports if now
they're going to game the criminal
justice system some tiny
fraction of them but i think that this
is a real possibility that we should
have our eyes open to the fact that
james tubbs facing long time becomes
hannah tubbs
gets the sympathy of the trans aspect at
the same time uh you know he said at the
time we told his father i was young and
i was hungry for some meat before going
after the child that could have worked
with gascone i don't know someone's
gonna have to ask him that
guy's a sicko and everybody should have
known about these tapes they did know
and the only reason that he reversed
this whole deal is because fox was gonna
break right right so the guy is a total
media front runner and here's what
happened so remember the home invasion
of the motown
co-founder where the wife was shot dead
that and the
i believe she was brentwood high school
but then ucla or usc girl uh who was
stabbed to death by the homeless perp
with like a slew of felony convictions
those two things have galvanized not
just
right-wing donors but now left-wing
donors in that whole area and they're
coming out of the woodwork to recall
this sucker you now have george
clooney's producer you have hillary
clinton's blunt bundler you have biden's
pick for the ambassador to norway and
ron berkel you know bill clinton's
friend you have sugar ray leonard
rosanna arquette they want to recall
this guy so now this is not even about
politics these are about people that
live in this area can't handle this guy
anymore and they want him done and i
think this really signals that he's
toast and and yet katie when the recall
election had its first uh rush i it only
got 40 percent of the votes it needed
yeah um you know this is a good lesson
in politics being local a couple years
ago the very
radical portion of the left decided that
they wanted to get a bunch of da's
backed by george soros into places like
la new york and san francisco and they
did it with tons of money and under the
radar because a lot of people weren't
paying attention to these elections now
with body bags stacked up and people
getting killed
people are starting to pay attention and
they're trying to recall them to get
these guys out because they weren't
necessarily a representation
of what people thought when they were
getting someone progressive about
criminal justice but overall the
philosophy has been proven that this is
this leftist uh ideology academic
philosophy about criminal justice reform
is crashing right into reality of what
criminals actually do to people when
they are allowed to just get out of jail
and shoot people in their homes without
any consequences identify however you
want so that you can get out of being on
the sex offender list that's this kind
of philosophy that's been implemented
with real world consequences for people
who have been killed and whose lives
have been changed forever and yet they
know we have the highest population in
jails of any nation in the world
we can't arrest our way out of it i get
white gasps
we can arrest criminals and deal with
that and the thing is about the internal
revolt so bill millusion our reporter in
la he finds out that these tapes exist
he calls and they say oh let us check
into that and that's when all of a
sudden they started to say oh we're good
they started back pedaling it's
gascone has no friends anymore i don't
think he's gonna have a single defender
he should resign
tomorrow
and because the other thing is that the
gentleman you saw shay sana who was had
the case he got reassigned
after he brought the tapes to everyone's
attention so that's what that's the kind
of retaliation this kind of the
prosecutor has provided to somebody who
was working hard to try to do the right
thing and that's why
you said 98 percent of the prosecutors
that work for him do not have trust in
him he's toast he should go tomorrow are
we going back to 1994 pete where are we
there
you know 98 vladimir putin couldn't even
get that back
if he wanted i mean this you're right
he's done yeah i don't see how he finds
his way through this we're we're already
there we're already there in new york
city we're moving back in that direction
the police are completely demoralized
they arrest people who are back we no
one understood the power of the d
excuse me lawyers understood regular
people never understood the power of a
district attorney right that most ninety
percent of cases are pleaded out and who
that district attorney is means those
people either get stiff sentences in
actual jail time or they're let out time
after time after time and jesse you laid
off that list of
celebrities and i know you know this
they deserve no credit i mean this is
all not in my backyard stuff if it was
on the other side of the coast they'd be
putting out videos about criminal
justice reform it just happens to be in
their neighborhood so will they learn
the lessons probably not but when it
hits them at the ballot box
you know maybe they'll
think otherwise are we going to do this
story today about uh trump's uh
prosecutors not
leaving resigning i think it could
happen later we didn't have it in this
particular show but it will be on it has
been on the air so two manhattan
assistant district attorneys resigned
over the progress of the trump
investigation effectively dropping that
investigation which was a bs
investigation from the get-go but you'll
hear more about it
don't take my word for it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else